-Let's get to the news.
Fox News announced today
that it has parted ways
with host Tucker Carlson,
and last Friday
was his final show,
which is great,
but also unsettling.
At least when he had a show,
we knew where he was.
It's creepy trying
to fall asleep
with a ventriloquist dummy
in your room,
but it's way creepier
when you wake up
and it's not there anymore.
"Huh.
That's weird.
Oh, my God. Is it behind me?"
Also today, CNN parted ways
with anchor Don Lemon
amid accusations
of sexist behavior.
Wow. Does anybody have
an opening for a sexist?
Oh, right.
[ Laughter, applause ]
President Biden is reportedly
preparing to formally announce
he is running for reelection.
If successful,
he will be the oldest man...
That's it. Just the oldest man.
That's right.
President Biden is reportedly
planning to formally announce
his reelection campaign
as early as this week,
which is frankly a little crazy.
He's going to be 82.
I think you should stop
running for president
when people start saying,
"Young" after your age.
"Joe here, 82 years young.
Not only that, the leader
of the free world.
That's pretty nuts."
President Biden met today
with three Tennessee lawmakers
who led gun safety protests
at the state capitol.
Meanwhile, Ron DeSantis
met with the guns.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Judiciary Chair
Dick Durbin in a new interview
called for a code of conduct
for Supreme Court justices
because right now, the only rule
is no front flips off the yacht.
[ Laughter ]
New Jersey Governor
Phil Murphy
recently declared
that September 23rd
will be Bruce Springsteen Day,
as opposed to Jersey's previous
Springsteen Day,
all of them.
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's has announced
it will offer
its Big Mac sauce on the side
for dipping,
or what the hell,
soaking.
[ Laughter ]
New York officials
unveiled a plan today
to install ten miles of bike
lanes throughout the city.
That story again --
New York officials
are adding ten more miles
of sometimes car lanes.
[ Laughter ]
IKEA announced plans last week
to open up eight more stores
across the US,
or more likely,
will start to build them,
get frustrated, and give up.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study --
We've all done that.
We've all done it.
According to a new study,
Americans over 50
who play video games
feel overlooked
by the gaming industry.
For example, there is no option
to play "Grand Theft Auto"
with your left blinker
on the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
70% of older Americans
who play video games
do not feel like products
are designed with them in mind
because when they tried it,
they failed miserably.
[ Laughter, groans ]
And that's sadly, because you
can't ever predict the future,
was our final joke...
of the monologue.
You usually try
to close on a banger,
and sometimes, you close
on one that goes like that.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden announced today
that he is running
for reelection.
Can you imagine if it's Biden
versus Trump again?
That's like
going into a diner
and the only things on the menu
are two day old egg salad
and Donald Trump.
"I mean, I guess I'll take my
chances with the egg salad."
President Biden announced today
that he will run for a
second term and said,
"Let's finish the job."
Yeah, good idea.
It would be nice
to have a country
where a guy could safely
retire before he's 86.
[ Laughter ]
Following President Biden's
reelection announcement today,
the Republican National
Committee released
an ad that asks,
"What if the weakest president
we've ever had were re-elected?"
And personally, I think it's
pretty low to drag
Martin Van Buren into this.
[ Laughter ]
Life's hard enough
with that silly haircut.
According to reports, Fox News
CEO Suzanne Scott
did not tell Tucker Carlson
why he was being fired,
but said that the decision
was made, "From above."
But come on, we know all
the decisions at Fox News
come from below.
[ Laughter ]
The Georgia...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Georgia prosecutor
investigating former
President Trump's
alleged interference
into the 2020 election
said yesterday
that she would announce
potential charges this summer.
I like that we're
spreading out Trump's crimes
and just like microdosing
indictments.
You know,
because like,
when Netflix drops
an entire season at once,
sure, it's fun that weekend,
but then we have nothing
to look forward to.
Once a week is way better.
It's like Trump's the "Abbott
Elementary" of criminals.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Idaho recently set
a Guinness World Record
after he passed
a 40 pound weight
from hand to hand 100 times.
That story again --
Not much to do in Idaho.
[ Laughter ]
He didn't even know
Guinness was there.
[ Laughter ]
They were like,
"Hey, how many times
have you done that?"
Moose -- A moose -- We like when
it starts "A moose."
A moose recently walked into
a movie theater in Alaska
and ate popcorn
from the trash can.
Or, as Regal Cinemas
calls it, a medium.
[ Laughter ]
Now movie theaters,
you used to...
And finally, a former
Disney World employee
was recently arrested
for allegedly
taking videos
of women's skirts.
To be fair, they should have
known something was wrong
when he showed up to work
with no pants on.
After announcing his 2024
reelection campaign,
President Biden delivered
a speech yesterday
about his economic vision
for the country.
That's right.
From now on,
the grandkids are getting $6
in their birthday cards.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
Vermont Senator
Bernie Sanders
endorsed President
Biden yesterday
and said he will do what he can
to make sure Biden is reelected.
But if Biden loses,
the two of them can always
go back to heckling the Muppets.
[ Laughter ]
Following recent reports
of Justice Clarence Thomas's
failure
to disclose lavish vacations
and gifts from a wealthy
Republican donor,
the Supreme Court released a
three page statement yesterday,
signed by all nine justices
committing to follow
"foundational ethics
and principles starting now.
I mean now.
Okay, now. Damn it, Clarence!"
That's right.
All nine Supreme Court justices
signed a pledge to follow
"Foundational ethics
and principles."
Okay, but it wasn't all nine
of them we were worried about.
I mean, Elena Kagan's
last vacation
was to the Lincoln Memorial.
Took the bus.
In honor of
Lesbian Visibility Week,
the cast of
"The L Word: Generation Q"
yesterday
visited the White House,
said Tucker Carlson
to a house plant.
[ Laughter ]
A top aide to Republican
presidential hopeful
Vivek Ramaswamy said today
that he will be polling
in second
or third place
by the end of the year,
unless, of course,
a fourth person joins the race.
[ Laughter ]
The USDA announced yesterday
that it is considering
making changes to limit
the amount of salmonella
in some chicken products.
I'm sorry,
they haven't already?
"We're also considering
a three strikes rule
if it's secretly a pigeon."
[ Laughter ]
"You can get
away with it twice.:"
Ben & Jerry's co-founder,
Ben Cohen,
recently launched a new cannabis
line called Ben's Best Blnz.
Hopefully it's a lot
more popular than Jerroin.
[ Laughter, groans ]
[ Applause ]
It was easy to do
because we had
a pack lying around.
Quarterback Aaron Rodgers
reportedly spent a week
in Costa Rica
at a spiritual healing center
before officially signing
with the New York Jets.
Which is like washing your car
right before it rains.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
was photographed
over the weekend at Coachella,
and even he couldn't believe
how much they were
charging for water.
And finally,
authorities in Mexico
recently seized
nearly 12,000 tequila bottles
that contained concentrated
liquid meth.
On the bright side,
Margarita night
ended with
a completely spotless house.
When asked yesterday about his
age as he runs for reelection,
President Biden said that it
doesn't register with him.
Okay. I know you're trying
to play it cool,
but you made it sound
like a symptom.
"My age?
I never remember."
That's right.
When asked about his age,
President Biden said,
"I took a hard look at it
before I decided to run,
and I feel good."
Listen, we don't care
how you feel now.
Did you see what eight years
did to Obama?
If you get reelected,
this is what you're going to
look like by the end of 2028.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden greeted kids
today on the White House
south lawn as part of
Take Your Child to Work Day.
Unfortunately,
it was a trap set up
by Congress
to arrest Hunter Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
new book, "Letters to Trump",
went on sale this week
for $95 -- $95.
Let me give you the gist
and save you the cash.
"Dear Mr. President,
for the last time,
the Grimace cannot attend
your inauguration.
We hope this will be
the final word on the matter.
Sincerely, McDonald's."
A source recently told
"People Magazine" that former
President Trump respects
and admires former
First Lady Melania Trump
and wants to make her happy.
But he plans to stay
married to her anyway.
[ Laughter ]
After being fired
from Fox News on Monday,
Tucker Carlson
posted a video last night
to Twitter
and said,
"Where can you still find
Americans saying true things?"
Well, hell, you've already tried
Fox News and Twitter.
I'm out of ideas. I don't know.
Maybe Wall Street.
A bipartisan group of senators
yesterday introduced
the Protecting Kids
on Social Media Act,
which would set the minimum
age to 13 for platforms
including Instagram,
Facebook, and TikTok.
Wait, you're trying
to keep kids under 13
from using Facebook?
What's next?
You're not going to let him wait
in line with you at the bank?
Workers in Wales recently
misspelled the word "school"
while repainting
a section of road.
To be fair, this is how
you spell "school" in Welsh.
[ Laughter ]
A court in Germany
ruled yesterday
that the tenants of a building
do not qualify for reduced rent
because their landlords
sunbathed naked
in the courtyard.
Said the judge,
"Think of it this way --
free sundial."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
I don't need your applause.
But I stand by that joke.
And finally,
according to a new report,
trained dogs can help detect
coronavirus infections
in schools.
Cats can, too.
They just won't.
That was the monologue,
everybody. We're off.
♪♪